pour en parler nous sommes avec xavier
moreau fondateur de ce rapport vont soit
xavier moreau merci d'être avec nous
plusieurs réunions donc un la semaine
dernière avec lé numéro deux de la
diplomatie on en a d'ailleurs parlé ici
même sur ce plateau avec de la fermeté
mais mes seins trop quand même car n'est
ce soir ses déclarations du porte parole
de la maison blanche la russie peut
attaquer l'ukraine à tout moment
pourquoi une telle déclaration
maintenant
écouter non c'est pas maintenant fait on
entend ça depuis à peu près deux mois
depuis le début du mois de novembre en
fait pour être précis on entend ça
beaucoup dans la presse américaine et je
pense qu'il s'agit pour le la maison
blanche de donner le change à la fois
pour son électorat démocrate et en même
temps pour les élites de démocrates qui
ne comprennent pas trop ce qui se passe
puisque qu'ils attendaient de joe biden
qu'il soit le vengeur de ce qui s'était
passé avec donald trump et depuis depuis
juin de l'année dernière on s'aperçoit
que la russie et les etats-unis essaient
de trouver une solution diplomatique
donc on continue à avoir des
déclarations des deux côtés d'ailleurs
c'est pas seulement du côté américain
mais du côté russe mais quand on regarde
en fait dans les faits les choses
avancent plutôt plutôt bien
chacun fait fait un effort le le sénat
les démocrates ont pas voté des
sanctions que réclamait le républicain
tom cruise au sénat donc le congrès
n'appliquera pas de sanctions
automatiques contre la russie donc ça
veut dire que joe biden le voulait
puisqu'il a obtenu le soutien de sa
majorité au congrès et d'un autre côté
les russes viennent d'arrêter un groupe
de hackers qui était responsable du
piratage du 'pipeline' coloniale en mai
2021 donc je pense qu'au contraire
toutes ces déclarations plus ou moins
agressives sont là pour cacher le fait
que la russie que les intérêts de la
russie à moyen terme c'est-à-dire
d'investir dans le donbass pour le
développer et de joe biden à court terme
c'est à dire les élections mi-mandat qui
auront lieu au mois de novembre et bien
les deux intérêts convergent donc ni
l'une ni l'autre des grandes puissances
n'ont besoin d'un conflit en ukraine
cela dit on va encore entendre des
déclarations comme on a entendu en fait
ce qui nous répètent c'est ce qu'on a
entendues au printemps de l'année
dernière on a eu une exaction n'était
pas parce qu'on est en pleine séance de
négociation d'une canne et la voix vont
encore se rencontrer vendredi ça veut
dire qu'en gros on fait une forme de
communication pour satisfaire les
opinions publiques et dans le fond vous
nous dites ce soir les choses avancent
et on va plutôt vers une désescalade
contrairement à ce qu'on peut entendre
oui dans dans les faits en fait si vous
regardez concrètement les étapes qui
sont en fait en dehors des discours vous
regardez les faits ça avance plutôt bien
gégéne citer deux choses
particulièrement concrètes si vous
voulez les états unis ne peuvent pas se
permettre d' une guerre dans le cren que
la russie remporterait en
semaine et qui provoquerait
l'effondrement de l'ukraine et contre
lequel les états unis ne pourraient
absolument rien faire donc ça veut dire
que joe biden se présenterait aux
élections de mi-mandat qui sont déjà
très mal parti pour le parti démocrate
avec un des plus gros échecs
depuis depuis la réunification de la
crimée où depuis la guerre en géorgie
donc ce serait une véritable catastrophe
pour pour le parti démocrate donc joe
biden ne peut pas se permettre une
guerre en ukraine et la russie n'en a
pas besoin parce qu'elle veut investir
dans la partie qui est
contrôlé par les républiques populaires
dans le donbass et donc elle n'a pas
besoin d'une guerre non plus sinon tous
ces investissements n'aboutiront à rien
n'empêche à la russie exige toujours on
parlait souvent de cette fameuse ligne
rouge à l'engagement de l'otan à ne pas
s'élargir en l'entrée de l'ukraine dans
l'otan toujours pas de réponse y a pas
de quoi s'alarmer
non parce que de toute manière ni
l'ukraine ni la géorgie ne peuvent
rentrer de l'otan dans la mesure ils ont
des territoires contestés la géorgie à
l'abkhazie et l'ossétie du sud et
l'ukraine a au moins la crimée et en est
en faite le
le don de base qu'elle ne contrôle pas
donc ça veut dire que si si jamais le
temps accepté l'ukraine ou la géorgie
dans son dans son
dans son giron comme membre de l'otan ça
veut dire qu automatiquement par exemple
la france et l'allemagne sera en guerre
contre la russie parce que quand vous
rentrez dans une alliance vous rentrez
avec un territoire et ça ni l'allemagne
ni la france ne le voudront donc en fait
à mon avis c'est un c'est un faux débat
c'est plutôt une manoeuvre assez habile
des ruches pour mettre les occidentaux
face à la réalité d'une situation qui
leur est défavorable et face au fait que
effectivement historiquement toutes les
promesses qui avaient été faites c'est
vrai non écrite mais
fusse-t-elle écrite aurait-elle été
tenus je ne pense pas aucune de ses
promesses n'a été n'a été tenu et donc
en fait c'est c'est plutôt une démarche
assez habile de moscou de mettre
l'occident face à ses responsabilités y
compris historique vous me parlez de
paris de berlin définitivement ces
négociations seront faites entre les
russes et les américains directement il
ya eu cette séquence dole et c'est eux
mais finalement le dernier mot c'est à
deux que ça se passe bah écoutez vous
voyez aujourd'hui sa grille lavrov
recontre s sont pour la première fois
son homologue
allemande madame b rock est en fait si
vous avez écouté la la conférence de
presse à l'issue de ce rendez vous c'est
ce qu'on a entendu c'est à dire que
madame barbe rock parler encore de
régler le problème dans le cadre du
format normandie et sari lavrov disait
mais moi je veux bien qu'on se
réunissent dans le format normandie
redon qui réunit les présidents
ukrainien russe allemand et français
mais d'abord il faut appliquer ce qui
était décidée en décembre 2019 dans ce
même format c'est à dire l'application
des accords de minsk rappelons au
passage à l'allemagne à la france que il
était garant de ces accords et que
c'était à eux de faire pression sur
l'ukraine donc le la russie et personne
n'ose dire le contraire veut réellement
régler le problème ukrainien dans le
cadre des accords de minsk et les
français les allemands n'osent pas le
faire et je pense que d'ailleurs c'est
ce qu'a dit sergueï lavrov dans cette
conférence de presse avec mme albert
brooks et que finalement les les
américains une approche beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus concrète et réaliste et
volontariste de régler le problème selon
les accords de minsk que les européennes
donc exit les européens et bienvenue à
la nouvelle discussion entre les deux
grandes puissances russe et américaine
justement ma dernière question est tendu
la main sur cette première rencontre
officielle entre sarria la mort et son
homologue allemand n'a quoi doit-on
s'attendre à l'avenir on sait que les
relations n'ont pas toujours été tendres
avec le gouvernement allemand les choses
vont empirer encore davantage écoutés
oui et non alors déjà les les relations
n'étaient pas si mauvaises parce que si
vous souvenez là pour la coalition
précédente c'est une coalition qui
rassemblait les chrétiens démocrates de
la cdu ou et les les sociaux démocrates
du spd les deux parties sont favorables
étaient favorables
à une bonne relation avec la russie mais
même s'il le disait pas ouvertement et
surtout à l'ouverture le plus rapidement
possible devant stream de là c'était la
première fois que sergueï lavrov
rencontré madame barbe rock qui elle est
une écologiste donc il s'est déclaré
pendant toute la campagne contre dans
scream 2 contre les énergies carbonées
etc etc qui a fait quelques déclarations
sitôt nommé aux affaires étrangères qui
ont été assez maladroite qui ont été
d'ailleurs démenties par le chancelier
scholtes donc du parti du parti
démocrate et là on a vu
on a vu surtout l'amateurisme de madame
mr brock en fait qui visiblement n'est
pas taillé pour discuter avec sergueï
lavrov mais cela dit elle a dit quelque
chose de très intéressant puisqu'elle a
invoqué plusieurs choix au début de son
de son discours la maison commune
européenne et ça si vous vous souvenez
c'est le discours de gorbatchev en 1985
ou en fait il essayait de créer cette
europe 2 pour paraphraser général de
gaulle de l'atlantique à l'oural et qui
n'avait rencontré aucun écho finalement
au sein de au sein des européens hélas
cette fois on est dans la situation
inverse sous scellés les allemands qui
essayent de venir chercher la russie
pour créer une europe justement extra
union européenne qui puisse
aller vers une voie pas s'y fier comme
l'espérait gorbatchev en 85 donc je
pense pas que ça change réellement le la
relation entre entre moscou et berlin
dans la mesure où l'allemagne des
impératifs industriels énergétiques et
elle a absolument besoin de la russie
elle absolument besoin de l'ouverture du
'pipeline' du gazoduc pardon dans scream
2 merci beaucoup en tout cas xavier
moreau nous avoir apporté votre analyse